[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden firmó la ley para Elevar el techo
de la deuda que evitó que el país
entrara en sensación de pagos y llegó
trazar las negociaciones entre
demócratas y republicanos el mandatario
Se comprometió a trabajar para
fortalecer la economía de Estados Unidos
ampliamos desde Washington
en México más de 15 millones de
ciudadanos están habilitados para votar
en las elecciones de este domingo en las
que serán seleccionados los gobernadores
de los estados de México y Coahuila unos
comicios que sirven para empezar a medir
el pulso de Cara a las presidenciales de
pese a la inflación interanual de casi
109% en Argentina el país es escenario
de eventos culturales que agotan
entradas a altos precios analizamos la
capacidad adquisitiva de los ciudadanos
si estos espectáculos sirven para
impulsar el turismo regional
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos porque el presidente Joe
biden firmó la ley que aumenta el techo
de la deuda la normativa fue aprobada
por el congreso tras largas y complejas
negociaciones entre demócratas y
republicanos el mandatario aseguró que
seguirá trabajando para fortalecer la
economía del país desde Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez nos amplia los
detalles
el gobierno de biden tenía hasta el
lunes dinero suficiente para pagar sus
deudas y obligaciones financieras y
evitar así el default tras la firma de
El acuerdo por parte de Joe biden este
acuerdo se convierte en ley el
departamento del tesoro de Estados
Unidos encargado de la política fiscal
del país tendrá hasta el primero de
enero del 2025 para seguir vendiendo
bonos y financiar sus actividades el
voto moderado de republicanos y
demócratas en el senado y en la cámara
de representantes fue clave para
asegurar la estabilidad financiera del
país en el pacto el gobierno de baile Se
compromete suspender los aumentos del
gasto público A cambio de que los
republicanos dieran su visto bueno para
levantar el techo del área según el
presidente ni demócratas ni republicanos
obtuvieron todo lo que querían en el
acuerdo pero se logró lo que los
estadounidenses necesitaban los
republicanos inicialmente mostraron
resistencia porque querían más del tres
coma tres por ciento de aumento en el
presupuesto de defensa que está por
debajo del aumento de la inflación anual
por su parte los demócratas pedían y se
oponían además menos recortes en el
gasto público y que no se aumentara la
edad para que los estadounidenses más
necesitados obtuvieran subsidios de
alimentación sin embargo programas
sociales como medicaidi Social Security
quedan intactos puntos que muy
probablemente usará como herramienta de
campaña para mostrar que es un buen
ejecutor y que puede lograr acuerdos
bipartidistas en medio de la
polarización que vive el país la
provincia canadiense de nuevo Escocia
continúa batallando contra uno de los
peores inicios de la temporada de
incendios forestales pues las
conflagraciones ya han quemado diez
veces el área promedio de otros años el
Primer Ministro justito prometió seguir
brindando asistencia Federal a las zonas
afectadas donde unas 30.000 personas han
tenido que ser evacuadas
vamos a México porque más de 15 millones
de personas están habilitadas para votar
en los estados de Coahuila y México el
más poblado del país para elegir
gobernadores las elecciones regionales
inauguran el calendario y servirán para
marcar el pulso político por la carrera
la presidencia en 2024 Mario carbonelli
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplió la
información
más de 15 millones de mexicanos están
llamados este domingo a las urnas para
elegir gobernador en dos estados de la
república al centro en el Estado de
México y al norte en el estado de
Coahuila en esta última entidad también
se renovarán 25 diputaciones locales se
trata de una jornada electoral con
características muy peculiares por
ejemplo en estos dos estados son los
últimos Coahuila y Estado de México
donde no ha habido alternancia política
es decir siempre ha gobernado el partido
revolucionario institucional el pri el
estado de México también que es la
entidad con el padrón electoral más
grande es decir más de 12 millones
700.000 electores será por primera vez
gobernado por una mujer Ya que en ambos
casos son candidatas se trata de
Alejandra del Moral de los partidos pri
pan y PRD y Delfina Gómez de los
partidos morena partido verde y partido
del trabajo también por primera vez 73
mil mexicanos residentes en el
extranjero podrán al consulado a votar
esto en Chicago Los Ángeles y Dallas en
Estados Unidos y también quienes residan
en Montreal Canadá si bien se trata de
comicios organizados por la autoridad
local la presidenta del instituto
nacional electoral Guadalupe tadey ha
dicho que las condiciones están dadas
que hay seguridad para que los
ciudadanos de estos dos estados acudan a
una de las veinticuatro mil urnas a
ejercer su derecho al voto esta jornada
electoral es considerada la antesala de
la elección Federal de junio de 2024
cuando se renovará la presidencia de la
República continuamos en México porque
las autoridades de Jalisco reportaron el
hallazgo de 45 bolsas con restos humanos
en un Barranco de Zapopan a las afueras
de la ciudad de Guadalajara las
autoridades señalaron que las
características de los mismos coinciden
con las de los ocho jóvenes
desaparecidos el 20 de mayo expertos
forenses indicaron que trabajarán para
confirmar el número de restos y las
identidades de los fallecidos Rafael
Pérez nos amplía
continúa la búsqueda de cuerpos humanos
cerca de Guadalajara el hallazgo de 45
bolsas con restos humanos encendió las
alarmas de las autoridades mexicanas el
descubrimiento se dio en el contexto de
la desaparición de siete personas según
el Gobierno Federal trabajaban en un
call center que estaría vinculado al
crimen organizado en esta zona opera el
cartel Jalisco Nueva Generación se han
estado manejando un número aproximado de
bolsas 45 50 bolsas obviamente pueden
surgir más que es lo que estamos
recuperando nada más quiero hacer una
precisión el número de bolsas no va en
razón del número de víctimas que se
están localizando las bolsas despiertan
el fantasma que supone el flagelo de las
desapariciones en la nación
norteamericana actualmente en México no
se conoce el paradero de más de 100.000
personas 15.000 de ellas están
reportadas en el estado de Jalisco allí
los familiares acuden a los sitios de
búsqueda con la esperanza de hallar a
sus parientes pero aquí estamos con la
esperanza de saber porque no nomás son
estos son miles Dónde están los de
nosotros dónde son miles de madres
buscando esperando la violencia es un
tema engorroso para el gobierno del
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
según el Registro Nacional de personas
desaparecidas en los tres primeros meses
de 2023 las desapariciones aumentaron un
20% más que en el mismo periodo del año
vamos Argentina para hablar de economía
porque este país registra una inflación
interanual del 108,8% y los niveles de
pobreza son de más del 30 por ciento sin
embargo se presenta un fenómeno que
llama la atención con el poder
adquisitivo de los argentinos estamos
viendo algo curioso Y es que los precios
de los productos básicos suben en
Argentina y hay personas que denuncian
que los salarios no alcanzan para comer
pero hay eventos culturales como
conciertos podemos mencionar Taylor
Swift que fue anunciado hace poco o
Coldplay que agotó diez fechas en el
Monumental o el mundial de fútbol de
Qatar con una importante presencia de
Nacionales argentinos conversamos
previamente con Mari Isabel Acosta
economista Argentina que nos dijo si con
estos eventos se puede hacer un análisis
de la capacidad adquisitiva de los
ciudadanos o es otra radiografía de la
desigualdad en el país
claramente es una muestra palpable de El
Avance de la desigualdad
y la mayor inequidad en la distribución
del ingreso que se produce como
consecuencia básicamente de la falta de
o de la pérdida de salario real de no
solamente de aquellos que tienen un
empleo en relación de dependencia de
manera formal sino del otro fenómeno que
avanza mucho en nuestra economía que es
el empleo informal y que no está digamos
no tiene los beneficios de por ejemplo
Los acuerdos paritarios Entonces eso
está produciendo un una al perder
salario real una la los niveles de
pobreza e incluso de indigencia que
vienen avanzando
paralelamente hay otro sector de la
población porque en 2021 y 2022 la
economía Argentina creció en valores
importantes pero
el avance de la desigualdad provoca que
haya un grupo más reducido de la
población que tiene acceso a cada vez
más niveles de ingreso Y eso es lo que
permite la aparición de estos fenómenos
numerosas ong alertan que la
deforestación de la amazonía brasileña
continúa un ritmo vertiginoso el grupo
Sin fines de lucro Río terrada plantado
millones de árboles jóvenes en un
esfuerzo de reforestación para restaurar
los bosques diezmados por la tala ilegal
y la ganadería en el área los
ecologistas indican que no son
Bienvenidos en muchas partes y reciben
amenazas
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]